you said that you were gonna be retiring  very soon yeah on your 40th birthday yes  is that right  yes this gonna be it for you it'll be it  my time I turned four I turned 40 March  20th next year I've got to fight as many  times as I can before that because I'm  going to ride off into the sunset I  brought my kids and my wife I told you  that's the bully Selena Cormier yeah  yeah I know told you about the ha ha  vacations everything they came got to  see me do this amazing man my career has  taken a turn in that 40 I'm done you  know what we are so happy for you I hope  your hand heals up soon I can't wait to  see you next time  and be well thank you so much for coming  by and thank you  [Applause]  you